SAFE IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THE
STUDENTS ARE DOING THIS MORNING.
BIG QUESTIONS REMAIN THIS
MORNING.
>>> A NEW STUDY SAYS THE STRESS
OF THE COVID PANDEMIC APPEARS TO
HAVE ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY CHANGED
TEENAGERS' BRAINS AGING THEM
FASTER THAN NORMAL.
LET'S GO TO DR. SANJAY GUPTA WHO
JOINS US.
IS THIS FROM LIKE STARING AT
SCREENS AND PHONES?
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> WELL, I GOT TO TELL YOU,
FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE THREE
TEENAGE GIRLS AT HOME.
SO WE SAW THIS PERSONALLY AND
NOW WE'RE STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND, GET A BETTER IDEA OF
WHAT EXACTLY WAS HAPPENING TO
TEENAGERS AND GET A GOOD IDEA OF
WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO THEIR
BRAINS SPECIFICALLY.
A LOT OF IT IS WHAT YOU SAY, THE
UNCERTAINTY OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT A LOT OF IT ALSO WAS THE
SORT OF REDUCED SOCIAL STRUCTURE
OF BEING AROUND FRIENDS AND THE
SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT THAT SIMPLY
HAPPENS BY BEING AROUND FRIENDS
AND OTHER PEOPLE DURING YOUR
TEENAGE YEARS IN PARTICULAR.
WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
WHAT ARE CALLED INTERNALIZING
SYMPTOMS THAT DEVELOP.
PEOPLE HAD INCREASED RATES OF
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION.
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERE WAS A
STUDY GOING ON WHERE THEY WERE
LOOKING AT ADOLESCENT BRAINS
DOING THESE MRI SCANS EVERY
COUPLE OF YEARS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW BRAINS CHANGE
SPECIFICALLY DURING THAT PERIOD
OF TIME.
SO THEY HAD THE STUDY UNDER WAY,
PANDEMIC HAPPENS THEY CONTINUE
THE STUDY.
SO THEY CAN LOOK AT BRAINS
BEFORE AND DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WHAT THEY FOUND WAS STAGGERING.
BASICALLY THEY SHOWED THE BRAINS
AGED MORE QUICKLY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THIS AREA OF THE BRAIN, THE
CORTEX, THINK OF THAT AS THE
BARK ON THE TREE, THE OUTER
LAYER.
IT GOT THINNER.
THAT HAPPENS WITH AGE.
IT HAPPENED MUCH MORE QUICKLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC FOR THESE
ADOLESCENT BRAINS, THE AREA OF
THE BRAIN RESPONSIBLE FOR
EXECUTIVE THINKING.
THE SAME TIME YOU LOOK DEEP IN
THE BRAIN, AREAS HERE WHICH ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR ABILITY TO
REGULATE EMOTIONS, FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY AGED MORE QUICKLY AS WELL.
SO ALL THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING SIMULTANEOUSLY, AND IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD
ACTUALLY STUDY IN THESE CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY HAD THE SCANS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND A YEAR
INTO THE PANDEMIC.
>> TEENAGERS LIKE TO REBEL, SO
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH
THEIR PARENTS WHICH I THINK WAS
CONSTRICTING FOR THEM.
USUALLY HOW THEY GAIN
INDEPENDENCE IS THROUGH THEIR
FRIENDS AND COMRADERY THEY HAVE.
THESE RELATIONSHIPS.
>> SURE.
>> MY QUESTION IS, I DON'T THINK
YOU CAN REVERSE IT.
YOU WOULD KNOW BETTER THAN ME,
HOW CAN IT BE NORMALIZED NOW?
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO GO BACK
TO NORMAL, IF YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> DON, YOU KNOW, IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME THINGS IN LIFE AND WITHIN
MEDICINE THAT JUST ARE WITHOUT
PRECEDENT.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A LOT TO
BASE THIS ON IN TERMS OF WHAT IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT WE CAN SAY IS THIS, THE
TYPES OF CHANGES SEEN IN THE
BRAINS DURING THAT TIME FRAME,
WITHIN A YEAR, SO A SHORT TIME
PERIOD, END OF 2020 THEY SAW THE
CHANGES, THEY TYPICALLY TAKE
YEARS AND YEARS TO DEVELOP THOSE
CHANGES.
AND TYPICALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
WHAT ARE KNOWN AS ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES,
WITNESSING VIOLENCE, THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY TRAUMATIC AS A CHILD.
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT TYPICALLY LEAD TO THESE
SORTS OF CHANGES.
WE SAW THEM MUCH MORE QUICKLY
WITHIN A YEAR.
IT MAY BE HARD TO READ THE
SCREEN THERE BUT BASICALLY YOU
SAW MORE INTERNALIZING SYMPTOMS,
ANXIETY, ISOLATION, DEPRESSION.
YOU DIDN'T SEE AN INCREASE IN
WHAT ARE KNOWN AS EXTERNALIZING
SYMPTOMS.
THOSE ARE RULE BREAKING,
AGGRESSIVENESS, VIOLENCE, THINGS
LIKE THAT.
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING.
YOUR QUESTION, HOW LONG DOES IT
LAST?
WE DON'T KNOW.
COULD THERE BE A REVERSAL OF
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES?
PERHAPS.
THAT IS THE HOPE.
THE STUDY IS GOING TO CONTINUE
FOR THAT VERY REASON.
>> I GUESS ALSO THE FOLLOW TO
WHAT DON WAS SAYING, CAN YOU
UNDO IT, BASICALLY, IS NOW THAT
KIDS ARE MOST OF THEM RETURNING
TO SCHOOL, THEY'RE BACK AROUND
THEIR FRIENDS, NOT HAVING THE
SAME RESTRICTIONS AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC, IF IT DEVELOPED
AS QUICKLY AS IT DID, CAN IT
HELP NOW THAT THEY'RE BACK TO
NORMAL IN EASING THAT FASTER?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY THE HOPE,
KAITLAN.
BUT I WANT TO BE CAREFUL HERE
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING SOMETHING
THAT IS WITHOUT PRECEDENCE.
SO TO TRY TO EXTRAPOLATE WHAT
THIS MIGHT LOOK LIKE IN A COUPLE
OF YEARS WE DIDN'T HAVE MRI
SCANNING IN THE LAST PANDEMIC,
1918, 1919.
WHAT WE DO KNOW, THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT OPTIMISTIC.
AFTER THE 1918, 1919 PANDEMIC,
THERE WAS AN ERNEST RETURN TO
NORMALCY, THERE WERE THE ROARING
'20s THAT CAME BACK AFTER THE
1918 FLU PANDEMIC, MIGHT THAT
HAPPEN HERE AS WELL AND MIGHT WE
SEE THAT REFLECT